[Music]
foreign
hi my name is Andrew Bray I'm associate
teaching professor at UC Berkeley in
statistics
I'd like to tell you my top three
reasons why you should take the advanced
cuarto with r r Studio Workshop
depositcoms this summer reason number
one projects in person
one of the real strengths of cuarto and
one of the focuses of this Advanced
Workshop is on quarto projects
these are complex works like websites
and books that allow you to unite many
different documents into a single
published work
this can be challenging to learn because
instead of just looking at a single file
you're looking at many documents that
exist in a directory that has a
particular structure
so for this Workshop we'll be preparing
ahead of time several project
directories that will help guide
exercises each one focusing on a
different aspect project functionality
so a big part of this Workshop will just
be looking at the structure of these
directories together in person and this
is really a terrific environment to
learn how these things work reason
number two programming Plus authoring
if you're coming to positconf I know you
like programming
if you're interested in carto I also
know you like authoring and Publishing
documents
in this Workshop we'll look at some of
the advanced features of parto where
programming and authoring start to merge
we'll look at how to pass variables
through documents and how to implement
listings we'll also see how to do
conditional formatting and how to set up
project profiles
learn how carto allows you to in essence
apply programming principles to the
authoring of your documents that's a
powerful paradigm reason number three
ask the experts Corto has grown Leaps
and Bounds over the last two years and
their more exciting changes that are in
the works
we'll be visited in this Workshop by the
Project's primary developers this will
give you a chance to ask them some
questions and hear about what's
happening at The Cutting Edge of quartet
so if you're ready to expand what you
can do with this powerful new tool
please join us at the workshop in
Chicago we hope to see you there
[Music]